to be honest it doesn't even feel like
riverdale anymore
who knew that a covid safety protocol
could massively benefit the actors when
it came to their makeout scenes
filming of the fifth season of riverdale
was unlike any other before the cast and
crew had to work with strict new rules
for the show to happen as safely as
possible
the actors experienced long days
grueling testing and new hobbies to keep
them occupied between takes
oh yeah there was also a whole lot of
mouthwash on set my first day back at
work
after filming was delayed due to covid
new safety protocols were put in place
so the production could resume filming
and get the fifth season off of its feet
before even being allowed to film every
cast member had to complete a two-week
quarantine
other protocols included loads of
personal protective equipment so much
that the sets looked a bit more like
hospitals than tv studios
staying safe
the makeup artists had to wear
protective gear whenever getting close
to the actors when preparing them for
set in addition to being surrounded by
plexiglas dividers while filming the
actors were also required to monitor
their health statuses and got coveted
tests three times a week if they didn't
adhere to these rules the actors would
be in breach of their contracts and
fired from the show this is the new norm
on set this is so crazy
one of the more surprising rules brought
on by safety protocols was the
introduction of mouthwash before kissing
kj appa and camila mendes made a whole
bit of their mouthwash rinse routine
before their onscreen smooching this was
definitely one of the new rules that the
actors were major fans of since everyone
who had to do a makeup for the show got
to enjoy super fresh breath this was
really nice
usually a table read will take place in
person with the whole cast and crew
together at a literal giant table but
this wasn't possible for season 5. the
very first read took place on zoom while
they were all in quarantine
none of the actors could stay together
while isolating so the whole team was
pretty distanced and faced the challenge
of trying to connect as dynamically as
they do in person they managed to have a
really productive read-through though
making sure everyone had time to catch
up and enjoy the excitement of the first
day
even if it was different this time
around
duty calls mental answers archie and
ko's boxing match didn't look this good
naturally behind the scenes the boys
went through a ton of practice sessions
on top of all their usual prep the
actors were often in fight rehearsals
and training to ensure the match could
be pulled off without a hitch for appa
the work doesn't really end the actor is
required to stay this fit for 10 months
of the year so while it may be tough
it's just a part of the job one part he
definitely excels at it's gnarly it's a
hard one
when they weren't filming the cast had a
whole lot of time on set to wait so some
of them decided to take up some new
hobbies madeleine petch could be found
cruising around the riverdale set and
threw the trailers on her roller skates
she wasn't the only one though lily
reinhardt rolled around the set too at
least after some very rough trial and
error when she first began learning in a
trailer on set luckily she improved and
the actors had a great new way to keep
busy and active between filming scenes
lord knows where we'll go next when they
weren't rehearsing for scenes or
learning lines the actors of riverdale
were busy in dance rehearsals with all
the dance sequences they've performed
before
the actors are no strangers to extra
rehearsal time with the wild
choreography we see in the prom scene
and of course this incredible dance
battle in the gym it's no surprise that
there were many hours spent dancing just
to make sure these numbers were on point
you know i usually have a rule about
annihilating high school students but
you seem insufferable the scenes in
riverdale aren't all filmed in order and
some days they would take advantage of
the set they were on and spent hours in
just one location one shoot day for
scenes at pops went extremely long
keeping the actors there until 4 am
that means i'll be in first thing in the
morning and there until pretty late at
night other days actors are required to
be on set before the sun even rises as
early as six or seven am
well it is currently six am
since coronavirus interrupted production
the riverdale storyline had to be
adapted the prom episode that opened the
fifth season was originally going to be
the finale of season four meaning more
than half of the episode had already
been filmed before they shot anything in
the fifth season this definitely
complicated the plan for the riverdale
team but also provided them with some
great footage to open season 5 with this
is a memory you were going to treasure
forever
with much of the fifth season taking
place seven years later and having not
finished the fourth season the way it
was meant to happen some reshuffling and
moving around of storylines was key the
original prom finale was meant to
include some significant plot points
that would set up the fifth season so
instead of diving into the time jump
quickly the production opted to do the
series justice and give the characters
the proper high school ending including
prom and their graduation
that's the riverdale and i want our
class to remember as we head into the
future
while it may seem that vanessa morgan
had the best pregnancy prosthetics for
season five the actress was actually
making it work on set while very
pregnant in real life in a week i'm six
months
instead of trying to hide it or taking
her out of the story the riverdale team
opted to use the pregnancy and wrote it
right into the show this was huge for
the actress who felt really accommodated
and supported by the team both on screen
and behind the scenes a definite dream
situation for morgan my name is tony
topaz and i am a guidance counselor at
riverdale high
credit must be given to her body as well
for working through those long and
intense days all while pregnant on set
challenge you to a dance-off i'm
pregnant does that mean you forfeit
if young hiram lodge looked familiar
that's because we've seen a spitting
image of his face on the screen before
the actor michael consuelos is the
actual son of mark consuelos so
who better to play the younger version
of him on screen i felt totally prepared
for it and then yeah i was working with
people i knew
in terms of prep to get into his dad's
role michael worked on his voice a lot
to make sure hiram's confidence came
through i took like a billion acting
classes uh to prepare for otherwise it
was a pretty natural fit in this case he
really was born with it what's my name
that's right
don't you ever forget
there was a whole lot more than just
lines and blocking to consider when the
riverdale actors were filming their
fifth season distance often has to be
maintained and everyone had to do their
best to remain six feet apart since
there were still some close-up shots
that needed to be filmed in close
proximity exceptions were made for those
actors to get into each other's personal
bubbles but only for a short period this
made for a lot of speedy scenes to keep
everyone as safe as they could in this
new kind of world that we're living in
there's no downtime on set because
they're so quick madeleine petch was
sometimes applying her own makeup on set
to help with distancing and keeping the
crew safe i just finished my makeup i
actually ended up doing a regular cheryl
look even when her makeup was done by a
makeup artist the actress would apply
touch-ups of her own so the look was
just right patch is pretty much a pro
when it comes to the cheryl look so
luckily it wasn't too difficult to pull
off let's go make a tv show shall we
lily reinhardt and madeline petch
weren't just actors on the riverdale set
they were also rocking their roles as
dog moms between takes with such long
days the actresses had their pups
accompany them to work and spent plenty
of quality time with them in their
trailers and just wandering around the
set
walking our puppies just walking our
dogs trying to find a patch of grass
somewhere we've loved having skeedl rich
portraying jughead's dad but as they say
all good things must come to an end the
actor not being part of the fifth season
had actually been part of the plan all
along marisol nichols was actually meant
to leave her role as veronica's mom as
well both performers felt it was time to
move on with ulrich feeling he wasn't
being challenged creatively anymore
fortunately there was nothing but love
from the whole cast and crew and no
drama regarding the decision nichols
however did end up returning to
riverdale and brought some great scenes
to life come on veronica that's reality
television what do you think we do they
may have faced some unexpected hurdles
and changed their routines but the cast
and crew definitely pulled it off and
brought another incredible season of
riverdale to life while the safety
protocols are intense we have a feeling
that the cast might just opt to keep
mouthwash before makeouts as a regular
practice